today on the matt walsh show netflix
employees stage a walkout in protest of
dave chappelle's comedy special as the
ceo of the company begins to cave as
expected also jen posaki has a good
laugh over the supply chain crisis it's
pretty funny she thinks katie couric
complains about sexism in the news
industry and texas passes a bill banning
biological males from female sports and
the media reacts in predictable fashion
to that and is there systemic racism in
the zookeeping community the washington
post says there is we'll discuss that
important issue and much more today on
the matt wall show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you know as an increasing number of
companies fall over themselves trying to
appeal to the left like netflix um
wouldn't it be nice to find one that
supports your values charity mobile is
the pro-life phone company they partner
with you to automatically support the
pro-life pro family charity of your
choice with five percent of your monthly
plan price and they've sent millions of
dollars to charities so far
and so you are just by signing up for
charity mobile you're helping to build a
culture of life in america and you're
also getting a great service at the same
time it's a win-win situation new
activations and eligible accounts get a
free cell phone with free activation and
it's really easy to switch you can keep
your existing phone number and you may
even be able to keep your existing phone
as well if you need a new phone no
problem charity mobile has a variety of
options from basic flip phones and low
cost smartphones to the latest 5g phones
monthly plan prices have just been lower
again
and now you can add even more lines to
your family plan as well they've got
great live customer service based right
here in the usa so switch to charity
mobile and support the causes that you
care about call them at 1-877-474
or chat with them online at
charitymobile.com and mention offer code
walsh now perhaps the state of our
culture in our country can be summed up
with this fact
we have been debating a comedian's
standup act for three weeks because he
said that only women can give birth
these these days almost nothing stays in
the news for three weeks afghanistan
only made it two weeks
mass shootings get three days at most
unless the shooter is black in which
case they get 30 minutes natural
disasters might get a weak depending
nothing remains relevant this long i
mean they could tell us that an asteroid
the size of alaska is gonna hit the
earth in three weeks and we'll have
stopped talking about it and moved on to
another subject ten days before it hits
we would notice a giant shadow being
cast on the ground we look up and say oh
yeah i forgot about that whole asteroid
thing and those will be our last words a
fitting and merciful end
the point is that it takes something
truly truly earth-shattering to attract
and keep our attention and a statement
like only women can give birth is what
qualifies in our day and age as truly
earth-shattering there's no sign
of this story story dying anytime soon
either as the media tells me that today
trans and non-binary netflix employees
and their allies will be walking out of
the job over at netflix headquarters to
protest dave chappelle's biologically
correct observations
now
if i were the ceo of netflix
i would respond to the walkout by
locking the doors behind them and
immediately turning on the outdoor
sprinklers
but the actual netflix ceo ted serrandos
doesn't quite have that in him now in
the early going sarandos did defend
chappelle and he he took a a a stand for
free speech allegedly
and he earned some pats on the on the
head and you know high fives from the
right for this response but i was a
little bit more circumspect
corporate america especially big tech
is run by a gaggle of glutenous timid
slugs i mean they've all had their
spines surgically removed
so that they can contort into whatever
shape is necessary is it possible is it
really possible that one of them would
actually stand up to this kind of
pressure
is it is it conceivable that one of
these floppy feeble little worms would
have the strength and will to defend a
man's right to make biologically
accurate assertions at a company special
well i'll believe it when i see it
and i don't think we're seeing it here
because right on cue
as the anti-science whack jobs walk out
of their jobs the ceo sarandos is is
beginning to waver this is from the
daily wire today it says netflix uh
co-ceo ted sarandos backtracked over
defending dave chappelle from the woke
mob on tuesday claiming that he quote
screwed up sarandos made the remark in
an interview with the wall street
journal in response to netflix's the
closer which has been widely praised by
many online and reviews with audience
scores reaching as high as 97 on the
popular website
to rotten tomatoes chappelle triggered
the far left with jokes about the trans
community defending jk rowling and going
after the lgbt community for trying to
cancel a rapper over a comment the
rapper made sorando said quote
what i should have led with in those
emails was humanity
i should have recognized the fact that a
group of our employees was clearly
hurting
to be clear
storytelling has an impact in the real
world sometimes quite negative
zerando said after he previously stated
the opposite and he continues we have
articulated to our employees that there
are going to be things that you don't
like there are going to be things that
you might feel are harmful but we're
trying to entertain a world with varying
tastes and varying sensibilities and
various beliefs
and i think this special is consistent
with that
so
the cave has begun in earnest now
granted
he's still defending the decision to air
the special but he's equivocating
because he's now validating the pain
that grown adults allegedly feel over
comments made during a comedy special
they're really hurting he says
this is always step one on the way
towards total submission and surrender
this is the bow
next he'll be on his knees and next
he'll be lying prostrate on the ground
and next who knows what he'll be doing i
don't even want to speculate
it's inevitable i mean it's it's it
always goes this way because there's no
midway point there's no neutral ground
between the rational side
and the side where a bunch of pink
haired weirdos are screaming about how
men can give birth too if they want
they the people on that side they give
you only two options reject them in
everything they stand for or fall in
line
nothing in between
rationality
cannot validate irrationality
when an adult is being unreasonable
there is nothing to do but treat them as
such
you know you cannot say to the
unreasonable person hey
you're totally unreasonable but i
understand how you feel and your
feelings are valid and important
no if you understand how they feel and
their feelings are valid then they are
being unreasonable
if they're unreasonable the only proper
response is hey you shouldn't feel the
way you do right now your feelings are
absurd and irrelevant to me and you need
to grow up and do better this is a you
problem
now this past weekend while the mob of
hyenas were barking at me because i made
a few basic common sense points about
paternity leave as we've discussed
um i did i posted one of my patented
non-apologies to twitter in the middle
of all this
here's what what it said what i posted i
said okay i've listened to your feedback
i understand that many of you are upset
about what i said many of you have told
me that my opinion was personally
offensive to you moreover my perspective
didn't match with your own lived
experience over the course of the last
couple of days i've had a chance to
reflect i never intended for my words to
cause division much less hurt and pain
this has been a wake-up call and it's
made me realize something i realize that
i'm extremely right more than more right
than i've ever imagined my critics are
wrong they're also disingenuous
insufferable and stupid and their
feelings are irrelevant i'm not sorry at
all and i never will be anyway while
you're here please subscribe to my
podcast
so i like to do this whenever i'm the
subject of outrage because
i want the outraged masses to feel
completely disregarded and trivialized
by me
i also want them to know that i'm
blatantly exploiting and profiting from
their outrage
and i'm doing it openly without apology
i believe that this is the only correct
response in these situations the only
one
but i did hear from quite a few people
on the right
over the weekend
who expressed disappointment in my
approach and insisted that i that i'm
being unchristian and unkind
they said that uh you know i can hold
the line and stand up to the bullies
without being such a jerk about it
notably none of the people who said this
to me have ever actually had thousands
of enraged psychopaths coming after them
calling for their job in their head
i deal with this three times a week
maybe you should defer to the person
with more experience in the field
but of course i realize
that my approach doesn't enjoy universal
approval among even my ostensible allies
but you should know why i take this
stance
in contrast to what ted sarando's
netflix is doing
it's because we've been gentle and
validating and kind to the anti-truth
tyrants for decades making sure to take
their feelings into account
even as they try to cut our throats and
ruin our lives
and eat our children's souls
and that's only fueled the very fire
we're supposed to be trying to
extinguish
it also drives them deeper into their
delusions
see when you show empathy to someone
who's unreasonable irrational and
disingenuous
you're only affirming them in that state
you are saying i understand where you're
coming from when in fact you don't
and you shouldn't
and you shouldn't pretend you do
this is no small point
this isn't some kind of game we're
playing our country is being driven into
absolute lunacy
total moral and intellectual collapse
is happening right now around us
it's real
you can't conceive of the sort of
darkness we're going to be living in and
our children will be living in
if we allow this collective march into
madness to continue a pace
this is not a time for tenderness
and politeness
or even kindness
now in quieter and calmer times you can
afford to be quiet and gentle yourself
but when your civilization is in free
fall
plunging into screaming insanity
it becomes necessary to raise your voice
be a little more abrupt
and firm
and yeah maybe a little rude too
we can play nice later
now is not the time
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
you know i'm a very particular person
someone call me picky i don't like it
when choices are made for me i like to
make my own choices and what if you were
able to do the same thing for hiring
choose your ideal candidate before they
even apply that's where zip recruiters
invite to apply comes in it gives you as
the hiring manager the power to pick
your favorites from top candidates and
right now you can try it for free at zip
recruiter.com walsh how does invite to
apply work well when you post a job on
zip recruiter they send you the most
qualified people for the job then you
can easily review the candidates and
invite your top choices to apply for the
job lauren webb svp of talent
acquisition
for mandela health raves about zip
recruiters invite to apply she says i
love that uh it features because we have
much higher follow-through rate if i
invite candidates it's easy for me and
it's easy for them in fact according to
zip recruiters internal data jobs where
employers use zipper crews invite to
apply get on average two and a half
times
more candidates applying you can see for
yourself just go to this exclusive web
address zippercutter.com
walsh walsh to try zip recruiter for
free that's zippercooter.comwalsh
ziprecruiter the smartest way to hire
speaking of um
places where where you shouldn't be nice
where it's not the time or place to be
nice
we talked yesterday i went into great
detail i think i probably went on for 15
minutes to close the show
about proper urinal etiquette and i
could have done 60 minutes on it it's
that important of a subject to me
personally and i think to society
and yet uh i spent all this time
talking about it
and then
we're i'm at an event uh
speaking at an event here in michigan
right to life event it's a great event
wonderful people
uh as always in the pro life movement so
the the nicest people you ever meet are
the pro-life movement
uh maybe sometimes a little bit too nice
because you know before i had to i i
went up there to speak i had to run to
the bathroom
and i go into the bathroom
and as soon as i walk in
there's a guy in there he says hey matt
walsh how you doing and he starts
talking to me
and i'm thinking dude why we i we just
had this conversation
this is not no no no
this this it's become a real problem
i've noticed
more and more
men not realizing i had the same thing
at an airport about two weeks ago now
you understand why i why i spent 15
minutes on it maybe i'll spend another
50 minutes on it right now
i have the same thing at it now at least
yesterday i was just walking in and the
guy talked to me
um
in in in general listen i think i'm
pretty approachable
well probably not approachable at all
but i'm not some sort of uh you know i'm
it's that's just my general aura i can't
do anything about that
but in in a in a bathroom is not the
place and then it was at an airport a
couple weeks ago
and at the urinal someone recognizes me
and starts talking to me i'm thinking
this you you can't do this this is this
should be a crime i should be able to
call security on you
so we're gonna we're gonna continue with
this conversation about your internal
etiquette until it improves
but there are also other things to talk
about like jen pasaki uh she was having
a good laugh over the supply chain
crisis
yesterday and it's funny to her i guess
let's listen to this
just a question on the timing uh on the
supply chain issue yeah um actions that
the president has taken
it was clear in march of 2020 when kobet
hit that that the supply chains across
the world had been disrupted even as as
the sort of work to fight back against
koba proceeded
people it was it was crystal clear that
things were not improving on supply
chain people couldn't get dishwashers
and
furniture and treadmills delivered on
time not to mention all sorts of other
things
so why the tragedy of the short the
treadmill that's delayed the trip
the tragedy of the treadmill that's
delayed that's just a bunch of isn't
that silly
you know we're talking about a lot more
than treadmills
pasaki
but even for the treadmills yeah there
is a tragedy in that too
there there are working-class people who
work in industries
assembling making distributing
treadmills and other exercise equipment
their jobs are on the line so yeah
there's a tragedy there even for
something as silly as a treadmill
but this goes far beyond treadmills
it's a it's all a joke to them
they it doesn't doesn't mean anything to
them
this is this is the one of the worst
kinds of crises
for these people to be in charge of
fixing i can't really think of a crisis
that they would be suited to fix but
especially not one like this
because they're not overly affected by
it
and uh they don't they don't understand
in fact we we've had
there's there's been articles i think it
was the new york times washington post
they're all the same it doesn't matter
one of these outlets published something
a few days ago saying hey stop it's not
a big deal stop stop complaining just
get used to it
i mean to them a supply chain crisis is
just
ah you know you ordered some some
christmas gifts and they're going to be
a little bit late a little bit late
no big deal
uh when in fact these are people's lives
and and jobs
that are on the line maybe not yours
it was the same thing with the with the
coveted lockdowns
hey it's no big deal just stay home for
two weeks three weeks four weeks five
weeks you know in fact let's make it six
months
our jobs aren't affected our our pay
will come come pouring in still
in fact if anything we're gonna get paid
more
but you guys will be fine
as i've said before they the thing is
they don't see
the ruling class uh the elites
they they really don't see the rest of
us as human beings i mean they they
might recognize us on some intellectual
level as being humans
technically speaking
but
but that's it
uh in every other sense to them we are
animals in an aquarium you know we're
like little pets
and as long as we're as long as we we
we're kept fed
and we are sustained in that way
and we're kept relatively comfortable
nothing else matters quality of life
what does that matter
you know how much
how much enjoyment you're getting out of
life that that doesn't matter either
that's why they can you know shut down
the school shut down the playgrounds for
a year
tell kids to stay home what do your kids
need to go into place it's a playground
it's just them enjoying their childhood
and their lives
what does that matter for
it matters for them because they're
humans but uh but not for us
just as when you see a gerbil in a in a
cage
you don't spend a lot of time thinking
about
is that gerbil really enjoying himself
how much joy can he really find in life
what is this what is the gerbils quality
of life
you might think about it for a second
and think wow that would kind of suck to
be a gerbil in a cage but then you move
on with your life
and that's how these people see us we
are we are gerbils and cages to
them all right here's uh so
texas has
is really on a roll uh first they passed
the bill
banning abortions after six weeks
and uh they're not slowing down this is
a good lesson what the republicans in
texas are doing
is now and has been for a while a good
lesson for conservatives and other
republicans all across the country you
stay on offense
you know i i think for for many other
republicans well they would never pass
that abortion bill in the first place
but if they did they would spend the
next six years
defending it and that's all they would
do
um
but
texas republicans they've said no we've
done that that's done
and uh and okay now we're gonna do this
and they've now passed a bill
that would ban biological males from uh
female sports
it also by the way
bans females from bio from from male
sports but that never really comes up
because you never you know you very
rarely see it in the reverse where the
females which which is a very which is a
very interesting phenomenon even though
transgenderism is far more common
um among adolescent girls
the sports issue is almost exclusively
boys trying to play against the girls
wonder why that is
so the legislator passed this build it
is now on greg governor abbott's desk
where i assume he will be signing it uh
today or or soon at least
and the media is responding as you can
expect and so is the white house this is
from axios says a white house
spokesperson on tuesday condemned a
texas bill that would force public
school students to play on sports teams
based on their assigned sex at birth
forced them for it would force them to
do exactly what everyone in sports has
been doing
from time immemorial
it would it would force them to do
exactly what we've all been doing
which is that you play against members
of your same sex
um
it's uh let's see here this this is
according to a white house spokesman
says this hateful bill in texas is just
the latest example of republican state
lawmakers using legislation to target
transgender kids whom the president
believes are some of the bravest
americans in order to score political
points
these anti-transgender bills are nothing
more than bullying disguised as
legislation and they undermine our
nation's core values
which values are those exactly that are
being undermined
by affirming the differences between the
sexes
and affirming that a boy who says he's a
girl
is still is still a male
what value is being undermined exactly
can you go to more detail about that
and as far as targeting transgender kids
the word transgender
isn't mentioned in the legislation
it isn't mentioned in any of these
pieces of legislation that we've seen
around the country
that's it there is no bill anywhere
saying that transgender kids aren't
allowed to play sports
and i tell you right now
whatever you think of me when it comes
to trans issues if if there were if if
there was a legislature trying to pass a
bill saying that uh quote-unquote
transgender kids aren't allowed to play
sports i'd be against that
because the point is precisely that it
it doesn't when you're playing sports it
doesn't matter how you internally
identify or how you perceive yourself
what matters is what biological category
you fall into that's it
as long as you're playing in your own
biological category i don't care how you
perceive yourself doesn't make a
difference
uh but the media of course going into
overtime
over this and we'll just play one
example here this is a local
news affiliate
in texas
um
trying to trying to show us the the pain
and suffering and damage that this bill
is going to cause let's watch this
governor greg abbott is expected to sign
this bill which requires athletes to
play on teams that align with their
genders listed on their birth
certificates proponents of the bill say
it will protect girls from having to
compete with stronger and bigger
athletes but trans athletes say it
unfairly targets them abc 13's puja
lodia has a story from an eight-year-old
in her fight for acceptance
sunny bryant and her mother becca have
testified in front of legislators in
austin multiple times they say they want
to share their story because they feel
like people will better understand their
position if they get to know them here
is my
hilarious comic sonny bryant is eight
now but she says she's known who she is
since she was four i am a girl
this is not pretend this is not a phase
it's real
it's there's a difference between saying
i want to be a girl and i am a girl
and that was
very clear by her
her family has been supportive and most
of her young classmates don't ask much
they've always played sports like
baseball and gymnastics because they'll
be expelled if they ask any questions
legislature began debating a bill that
would make it so that she will only be
able to play on boys sports teams she
and her mom went to austin it was kind
of emotional
and
no i was kind of the mom went to austin
and dragged him along search of a
problem we haven't had any lawsuits in
the state of texas we haven't had any
cases and the population of trans kids
kids is so small so that means she'd be
the only girl in a locker room only girl
on the team she won't have that
community that you get i like baseball
tennis
gymnastics
and soccer what is in my heart is
i think i should be able to play sports
because i am a girl too
sunny is still only eight years old so
her mother says
so we're supposed to believe
this this kind of thing it enrages
it arranges me every time i see it it
will never not enrage me
to see kids being treated this way
by that
i have to stifle myself
i you know i know i just said but we
can't be we can't worry about people's
feelings of being gentle and everything
but um i also don't necessarily
want to get completely de-platformed um
that mother here's what i'll say about
the mother
there is no eight-year-old
on the planet
who is saying to
their mother
oh let's go to state capitol and lobby
over this bill that's being proposed
hey mom i want to become a political
activist
that's what i want to do
i have eight-year-olds i have two of
them right now
they have no idea what bills are being
passed
the state legislature let's go to the
state capitol and lobby over bills
they're not thinking about that
you know what my son is thinking about
he's thinking about uh he wants to go
outside and and run around and wrestle
around with his brother
and uh and throw rocks at various
objects
they could they could go outside and uh
and that's that's an afternoon i mean
just picking up rocks and like throwing
them at trees
i've told them don't throw them at
anything that's alive but other than
that
throw all you want
that's what they're thinking about
no no eight-year-old so we're supposed
to believe that this eight-year-old
has chosen to become a a political
you know advocate has chosen to be the
face of of transgender rights in texas
just like we're supposed to believe that
at four-year-old at four years old this
boy
discovered his inner female identity
and that that mother says well there's a
difference between saying i want to be a
girl and i am a girl yeah really what's
the difference exactly what is the
difference
when a four-year-old says it
is there a difference when a
four-year-old says um
i am a lion versus i want to be a lion
there's no response we we
this of course is the point that we on
the same side have been making one of
the points
which is that little kids
have no concept of their own identity
they have extremely active imaginations
they get into phases that can last
sometimes for
months or years even
and sometimes kind of weird phases where
they get really obsessed with a certain
idea or concept or or imaginary thing
that's all perfectly normal for kids
which is why a young child can claim to
be an animal or a superhero
or some sort of mythological being
and really believe it on some level
because for to to them the distinction
between playing pretend
between using your imagination
and reality you know there is really no
distinction
that's why at four years four years old
uh you could have a kid who who
almost every parent on the planet at one
point has had a conversation with their
child
about how there's no monsters in the
closet here i'll open up the closet for
you shine a light into it there's no
monsters you see there's nothing in
there
but they don't understand that because
in their heads they feel like there's
monsters in the closet and so the idea
that they could feel that something is
true and yet it not actually be true
that's not something that they can wrap
their heads around yet
so we keep making this point and the
other side all they do is scoff that oh
this is totally different a
four-year-old saying they're a
four-year-old boy saying he's a girl
he's not the same as a four-year-old boy
saying he's a dog really it isn't how's
it any different tell me
if we on the sane side if we ran society
you know if we had not ceded and
surrendered our society the way that we
have uh that mother will be going to
prison for the rest of her life which is
where she belongs
this is her this as i always say this is
munchausen by proxy this is her imposing
her delusions her sickness her mental
illness onto that child
and then and then tracing him around
like a like a trophy
like a little mascot like a
a prize that she's been awarded
you know we hear about men that have
trophy wives well there are parents that
make little trophy children for
themselves
so they can earn woke points and they
can earn social credibility they can up
their social score
and so they could show the entire world
look at my trans child
i have no sympathy for these parents at
all
i know some people do they say well look
at these parents you know they
they're in a difficult situation they
don't know what to do no no sympathy
look if if you're a parent and you're
adult and you're a good parent and
you've raised your kids the right way
and your 14 year old girl goes to public
school and comes home one day out of the
blue and says i think i'm a boy
i have sympathy for you there in that
case with with adolescent girls
or boys
who um just one day out of nowhere get
this idea in their head
and uh and you've got the school system
working against you all of their peers
everything in the culture and media i
mean that's one thing but if you're a
four-year-old
you know if you're a parent with a
four-year-old quote transgender
that's on you
and that is really easy that's that's a
really easy problem to solve
very easy
the only way that problem maintains is
if you want it to be that
way all right what else we got here so
okay i wanted to play this for you as
well i've had this for a few days to
play there's a show on hbo called scenes
from a marriage and uh it's all about a
marriage falling
apart and this is a
like i said a show i think it's like
eight episodes long so
this is eight hours eight to ten hours
of sitting there and watching a marriage
fall apart
i'm not exactly sure what would drive
someone to spend their time especially
if you're if you are a married couple
and you're gonna say to your wife hey
honey you know everything's going well
for us let's spend um let's spend eight
to ten hours uh you know immersing
ourselves in the story of of someone
else's
marriage disintegrating
that seems like that could be something
that would really affirm us in our and
and strengthen us in our relationship so
uh for whatever reason this this show
exists and people watch it
and the lead actress jessica chastain
was on the view
bragging about her feminist convictions
uh in refusing to go fully nude unless
the man in the show also is fully nude
listen
there was a full frontal nude scene to
everyone
and i'm sorry
[Laughter]
i'm feeling objectified right now so she
gets all the deep questions yeah i just
i just
hate to do oh but i have to ask
um you know it really you want to know
it really set everything on fire twitter
we were talking about it were you
surprised at that reaction um and was
there ever a moment where you sort of
second guess your decision to
reveal yourself you're welcome
welcome twitter
i i was surprised because i didn't know
that was going to happen
i had been you get sent the stuff to
look at to be like okay i'm fine with
that but i saw it on a laptop quite dark
and i didn't notice
uh what was happening down there and the
surprise surprise so it was a surprise
when i started seeing all these like
things like it's full front they're like
no what are you talking about tonight
and i saw it then clear clear as day on
the big tv there it's it's there wow
it's like everyone too it's like
surprise mr house
[Applause]
well i mean i said to a guy who wrote
and directed the series in the very
beginning i said i'm comfortable with
all the nudity
but any part of my body that you show
you're gonna have to show the same with
oscar so like there's a shower scene
that i have in episode two right and you
see my body and so now like you see his
body so that's typical though it's a
woman's body yeah but so for me though i
wanted it to be balanced that's so bold
though you said i i'll do it but these
need to be the terms who is watching
this show
speaking of why i mean it seems for me
from marriage who's watching that but
but even more so
who's actually sitting down to watch the
view
does does anyone
or does this show just live on viral
clips
that are mostly shared around by people
who hate the show like myself
but this is uh here we have this is what
this is what feminism is now
yeah sure i will uh you know degrade
myself i'll take my clothes off on
camera that's perfectly fine as long as
he's degrading himself too if we could
degrade ourselves together
then uh then somehow it balances out and
we have protect and both of us have
protected our dignity
this this to me is is very similar to
the hooters situation that we talked
about yesterday
women signing up to
become waitresses at a place called
hooters
where the food is terrible because
they're not selling food
they're selling the waitresses that's
what they're selling so people can go
and look at the waitresses you sign up
to to do that
to really sell your body i mean visually
at least
and uh but but then they draw the line
and say oh these shirts these these
shorts are a little too skimpy i'll go
with the extra skimpy shorts i'm fine
with that but not the extra extra skimpy
shorts
that's over the line sir
i have standards as a woman
so this is very similar to that
we
see the the impotency of feminism
which is inevitable that feminism will
become as impotent as it has been when
feminists are also most of them
perfectly perfectly willing to sit back
and watch as as men
are
are
you know appropriate their identity and
i wonder how many feminists with with
rachel levine yesterday being awarded
for the first quote female
four-star admiral
how many feminists look at that and
actually feel that the glass ceiling has
been broken for them
yeah look at this
rachel levine breaking up that old boys
club
this old white man
breaking up the old boys club i wonder
how many see it though of course they
don't but they remain silent and because
uh
you know they've been scared into
submission and so feminism has become
this pitiful pathetic impotent little
thing
and that's what it is now
it's not hey i refuse to take my clothes
off i'm not gonna do that this is
gratuitous it's not necessary for the
story there's no reason why you need
full frontal nudity for me to tell this
story about the marriage falling part
you don't need that
now she's not taking that stance she'll
still do it
as long as the guy is too
as long as we can all march together
into our own um
humiliation and degradation then
everything will be fine
all right let's move now to reading the
comments
who's rocking polka dots without shame
do you know their name
they're the sweet baby gang
[Music]
uh rachel says matt how do you reconcile
being a masculine man and wearing makeup
well it's a rachel's a tool to trade but
they're construction workers for them
it's a hammer
right for a police officer he's got his
gun
a lumberjack has his axe
i have makeup
i feel like i didn't do myself any
favors with that answer whatsoever but
there it is
um
bd says
uh late upload today thought you pulled
a butt gig for a second
you thought i was doing what now
buddha judge i said okay so did you you
thought that i was going on paternity
leave rather than putting the show up uh
yeah it was a little bit late but but we
got it up so no reason for complaints
um
kyle says matt used to give the
impression that flying was mostly just
an annoyance for him but he's made it
clear and clear lately that he's just
afraid of it
my wife is a little afraid of flying but
it's never bothered me in the least
i hate the in-ear pressure issues that i
get sometimes and it's even caused some
pretty bad sinus issues which may last
days or even weeks after the flight but
i've never been afraid of flying i
actually enjoy it assuming it's not too
cramped and crowded well nice for you
kyle uh like i flying is the only thing
up
i am afraid of one thing i fear only one
thing and that's it it's just flying
and spiders but those are the only two
things
uh joy says matt please don't give
anyone a relief band as a gift i
question when he says those comments if
it's quiet sarcasm on his part these
these accusations
that i get during the comment section
that i am anything less than sincere
enthusiastic when i am reading
advertisements from our from our
fantastic sponsors
i take i'm starting to get personally
offended by it
first of all i would never engage in
sarcasm you know that
uh
kade says matt matt planes literally
give people in the exit row a packet
with everything they have to do in the
event of an emergency
uh yeah yeah they tell you that but
nobody never looks at it and i don't
want to be the one dork
who actually i've been i've i said the
eggs are every time i get it every
chance i get and uh so i've give i've
been giving this speech a hundred times
and they say well exit row you got to
help people get off the plane there's
more information packet no one ever ever
picks that thing up and looks at it
and so i'm not going to either so i sit
there in ignorance
meaning that when the time comes if i'm
actually called upon i won't know what
to do and everybody on the plane might
die just so just because i didn't want
to look like a dork and read the packet
and sean says three stooges wore dresses
they did it better than harry
yeah there are so many examples um
throughout history of men wearing
dresses
especially in modern history and the
comments yesterday a lot of people
giving other examples as billy porter
claims you know claims that he was the
first
he was the the first man to wear a dress
he invented this
dennis rodman wore a wedding dress to
when he married carmen electra and they
stayed married for
you know 12 days or whatever it was
so this has been happening men have been
doing this but here's the difference
there is there is there is a difference
there has been a change okay when it
comes to this
and the difference is that you talk
about the three stooges
they were men wearing dresses
because it's funny it was supposed to be
funny like you'd laugh at it
you would see it as absurd
dennis rodman wearing the wedding dress
it's it's it's supposed to be absurd
it's something that you gawk at
and dennis rodman was all about being
gawked at and so that's that's what it
was
um now the only difference now is that
men will do this
and expect to be taken seriously
so it's the it's the
it's not the men man wearing the dress
that's different it's the man wearing
the dress with the self-serious
self-aggrandizing attitude
that's the only the only difference
and despite that attitude they have the
fact is it will never not be ridiculous
you're a man you put on a dress you look
absurd you look ridiculous
and you deserve to be laughed at as i'm
sure you already know uh october is
cyber security awareness month there's
always something that we should be aware
of for each given month and this month
it's cyber security and this year's
theme is do your part be cyber smart
getting cybersmart starts with a cyber
hygiene which is basic habits that can
help
keep you and your family protected from
identity theft scams and other online
dangers examples of good cyber hygiene
include using strong passwords setting
up multi-factor authentication on your
accounts and regularly updating software
on your devices listen every day we put
our information at risk on the internet
in an instant a cyber criminal could
harm what's yours your finances your
credit good thing there's lifelock
lifelock helps detect a wide range of
identity threats like if your social
security number is for sale on the dark
web if they detect your information they
will send you an alert and if something
does happen god forbid to your identity
they also have their identity theft
restoration specialists who are on staff
and ready to help you out with that
nobody can prevent all identity theft or
monitor all transactions at all
businesses but you can keep what's yours
with lifelock identity theft protection
join now and save up to 25 off your
first year at lifelock.com walsh that's
lifelock.com walsh for 25 off
and there's more when it comes to the
facts the daily wires newest podcast
morning wire has a never-ending supply
not only has it been topping the apple
and spotify charts since its release
it's the only daily podcast that values
your time and the truth and while we're
working overtime to bring you the news
you need to know
we need your help to keep the facts
trending towards number one so subscribe
and start listening right now to
morningwire on apple spotify or wherever
you listen to podcasts and leave a five
star review
if you like what you hear and even if
you don't leave it anyway be a nice
person now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
today we have to cancel the washington
post for an article published yesterday
with the exceedingly bizarre headline
zookeeping isn't common in the black
community
this black zookeeper wants to change
that
now if you have a moderately well-tuned
bs detector
you hopefully have already noticed a
major problem with the claim being made
here
yes zookeeping isn't common in the black
community it also isn't common in any
other community
zookeeping is among is common among
zookeepers and that's it
from what i've read statistically over
90 of zookeepers engage in zookeeping
but the numbers are considerably lower
for all other communities including
white people i've been a white person
most of my life and i've never known a
zookeeper it's not like zookeeping is a
profession that white suburban parents
tend to push their kids into
growing up i never had a friend tell me
man you know i really want to be go to
school and be a doctor but my dad is
pressuring me to keep zoos
he won't shut up about it
you know he says i was a zookeeper
my father was a zookeeper
son you come from a long line of
zookeepers
now that's not a conversation i ever had
but let's not let any of that get in the
way of racializing the zookeeping
profession so here's the washington post
craig sappho was at fresno chaffee zoo's
big cats exhibit
when he saw the man
outbounds this black guy in a zoo
uniform sappho said he had this walk
like the coolest walk you'll ever see
and i think ah that's cool they let
their volunteers come in
then he realized the man wasn't a
volunteer he had his training buoy his
target stick his meat pouch sappho said
and he realized
oh my god he's the keeper
now just interject here
you should not be walking around the zoo
with your target sticker meat patch meat
pouch out um
you should there are children present
but that's neither here nor there back
to the article it says the man didn't
fit the profile of who most zookeepers
in america are white and female i was
mortified that i said that saffo said
because like the man in fresno
california he was watching during a
conference in 2018
and sappho too is a black zookeeper zafo
47 is the curator of large carnivores at
the smithsonian's national zoo in dc and
for decades he has often been one of the
few if not the only zookeeper of color
in the room
even as his responsibility and prestige
in the field grew his black friends
would dismiss his work as white people
stuff and indeed the field is about 74
white
now he's like 74
white but white people also comprise
about the same percentage of the overall
population in the country that would
mean that white people are
proportionally represented among
zookeepers what's the problem here
and even if zookeepers were 100 white
even if there were no zocs zookeepers of
color still what's the problem here
we'll have to read on to find out
it says when he was at work at the
national zoo where he's been for more
than 25 years
people who didn't know him often assumed
as saffo did with the black zookeeper in
fresno that he's a volunteer or even a
janitor the same thing happened to
jordan weasley an animal zookeeper at
cougar mountain zoo in washington state
who said that he gets asked if i'm if
i'm a janitor or if i clean the
bathrooms when he's walking around the
zoo
now another brief side note
um that doesn't happen i mean i don't
mean to question jordan weasley's lived
experience but i don't think that
happens nobody's walking up to a random
black guy at the zoo and saying excuse
me do you clean the bathrooms
that's the kind of thing that you think
white people would do if you've never
met one in person and have learned about
them only through ibramex candy seminars
no white person is just going to go up
to a black eye and say you there yes
yeah the toilets are unsightly in the
restrooms please attend to them at once
i assume you're the janitor after all
i'm just i'm skeptical about that but
let's keep reading a little more it says
veasley32 whose social media posts as
jungle jordan are wildly popular finally
tackled his um
his unicorn status in an emotional viral
video
okay we have to stop again because you
know i had to go find that emotional
viral video about black zoo keeping and
i did find it
and this viral video by the way was
filmed in 2018 and has 4 000 views on
youtube so we're really stretching the
bounds of the viral designation here
unless the guy unless they meant to the
guy filmed the video
while sick with a virus i'm not sure but
anyway here it is
[Music]
what is up everybody it's your boy
jungle jordan as you can see by the
title of this video this is a really
important video that i've been wanting
to make for a long time and it's a
pretty emotional topic for me and that
but i feel like this needs to be said
and everything i'm about to say means a
lot to me and it's really close to my
heart it's really hard to talk about so
like i said took me a long time to even
try to attempt to make this video even
as i'm filming right now it took me a
long time to try to think of an intro of
how to start this video so i'm going to
just get off and get into it i'm going
to start by saying i
am a black zookeeper now this means a
lot there's a lot that comes with this
with this phrase there's two words there
black zookeeper
both probably words you would have never
heard combined together matter of fact
never probably have seen those words
combined together but yes we do exist
well yeah i mean those aren't words i
hear together very often because i
rarely talk about zookeepers no offense
i don't hear any words combined with the
word zookeeper because this subject
simply doesn't
come up very often in my life and on the
rare occasion that i have had the
opportunity to discuss zookeeping in any
depth
i would normally refer to the zookeepers
as just zookeepers without feeling the
need to fix any racial designation to
them
i mean now that you mention it i did see
an asian zookeeper at a zoo a few weeks
ago but i didn't go up to them and say
excuse me asian zookeeper i have a
question
in fact i didn't think of them as an
asian zookeeper at all really i think i
just thought of them as a zookeeper who
happened to be asian
but all that is beside the point
i go back to the question i posed at the
beginning
even if black people are
under-represented amongst you zookeepers
why is that automatically a problem why
does it matter
see this is what the racialists do they
walk around the country randomly poking
their heads into rooms and saying hey
there should be more black people in
here
that doesn't they don't seem to care
much about the math
there are a finite number of black
people in the country in the world even
there's only so many to go around and
yet and yet they demand dramatically
increased numbers of black people and
other racial minorities in every in
every field and in every walk of life
and in every nook and cranny of society
but then the math doesn't work
if you insist on more black zookeepers
and your demands are fulfilled
that's going to mean fewer black people
in whatever field or profession they
would have gone into instead
that problem should be apparent i would
think
also nobody's talking taking into
account free choice
each individual black person in the
country
is a human being with free will
if not many of them become zookeepers
it's because not many have decided to
make that choice with their lives
you can create more black zookeepers
only by convincing black individuals
to not choose whatever they were going
to choose and choose zookeeping instead
but in what way does that represent
progress that's a lateral move that's a
reshuffling
you're shifting pieces around on the
board you're not adding new ones
or perhaps i'm looking at this the wrong
way
if we can't increase black
representation in zookeeping by
increasing the volume of black
zookeepers the other option is to
decrease the volume of white zookeepers
maybe we should fire 95 percent of the
white zookeepers across the country
thereby tripling the percentage of black
zookeepers in one fell swoop
better yet the most equal thing would be
to have no zookeepers at all
open the cages let the animals wander
around
as they will
that would be true equity
it would also make for a much more
entertaining zoo experience
and most importantly racial balance at
the zoo will finally be the last piece
we need in order to usher in racial
harmony across the globe
seems like a crazy plan perhaps
but it's better than the one offered by
the washington post and black zookeeper
craig saffo and that's why they are both
today i'm afraid to say
cancelled
and we'll leave it there thanks for
watching thanks for listening have a
great day
[Music]
godspeed matt walsh show is produced by
sean hampton executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover
our technical director is austin stevens
production manager pavel vadasky the
show is edited by ali hinkle
our audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair makeup is done by cherokee heart
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matte wall show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 21.
a man without any military experience
becomes the nation's first female
four-star general the cdc accidentally
admits that abortion is infanticide and
the washington post tells you to stop
complaining about the supply chain
prices check it out on the michael
knowles show